we're so Game of Thrones season 8
episode 4 it's aired I've seen it we're
gonna talk about it here that is so
spoiler warning I'm gonna talk about
some things that you might not want to
know if you haven't seen Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 4 but if you have seen
it and/or don't care well this videos
here for you and for this video and all
Game of Thrones videos I'm doing for
Game of Thrones Season 8 this video is
brought to you by the Stardust app click
the link below download the Stardust app
follow me at Jeremy Jon's react to Game
of Thrones episodes on the start a stack
tag me in those reactions that'll enter
you for a chance to win a trip for you
and a friend to go down to Los Angeles
California for the Game of Thrones
series finale the Stardust people are
putting that on I'll be at that party
and yes the first winner has been chosen
and I'll tell you at the end of this
video
do it now come on we got to talk about
Game of Thrones first then I'll tell you
the first winner
so for episode 4 of season 8 I went back
to what I liked about Game of Thrones
personally you had this huge battle the
Battle of Winterfell that that battle
have the consequences that maybe Cobra
Kai season 2 had no I feel like that
episode split the fan base it felt like
there are two kinds of people watching
Game of Thrones right now people who are
like the zombies from the north but
that's the point of the show people like
me who are like I like the scheming in
the politics in the dialogue and let's
give me that what I've liked about it so
now we know some people were like yeah
the battle was fine and other people
were like that was the most
disappointing moment in television
history but I was there for the last
season of Dexter horizon the last four
seasons of Dexter I've seen worse but
now they're licking their wounds before
they go to King's Landing for the final
battle that was like you're all doing
the Robert Baratheon you're drinking and
[ __ ] yourselves into an early grave I
get it you got to blow off some steam he
just had a huge battle with zombies what
man there are only two episodes after
this episode we got to speed it up I
mean I like those character moments that
I just wish this season had more
episodes but I guess that's why is
advantageous if these episodes are a bit
longer so you can just kind of have the
best of both worlds or at least attempt
to have the best of both worlds but when
it looked like it was just gonna be a
bunch of people hanging out in
Winterfell I was like oh man but then
they go to King's Landing which used to
take a few episodes then it took one
episode now it takes like five minutes
of an episode that time went by fast and
now we're setting up for the final
battle but I was a bran come on Bron
Bron like stole the episode that's seen
with bran talking to Jamie and Tyrion
Lannister that was that bran is straight
up he's Kano I loved Kano
and I loved bran what can I say I love
douchebag mercs sue me but my favorite
moment in this episode other than bran
talking to Tyrion and Jaime Lannister
when Tyrion in ferris were talking
because there's some real tension there
Varys is like Daenerys is kind of losing
herself I don't think she should be on
the throne I think it should be Jon Snow
Tyrion apparently not as smart as Varys
now because Darren's like no our queen
but she's clearly hmm I mean I've been
rooting for her from the beginning but
at a point I was like oh she looks like
she might have that Targaryen [ __ ]
nature to her still want to see where it
goes because she's cool and now that we
have an alternative yeah why not maybe
the alternative should run things either
which I don't care who either of them
could just blast that smug ass smirk off
of Cersei Lannister's face I'll be happy
people in Winterfell are dumb though
it's like no one knows that high school
doesn't end after high school
everyone gossips why would you tell
people this [ __ ] Jon Snow's like I
shouldn't tell people my lineage okay
I'll tell you too then again bran kind
of blew the whistle he's like so to you
I feel like um I don't know he's talking
about I was he's stupid I was trying to
pick between red and green apples but
now he told his sisters a secret 27
people weren't gonna know by the hours
and I have to think Jon Snow has an
ulterior motive like he actually does
want the throne because he's telling
sauce of this big secret that will make
Sansa go you know what I didn't like the
Queen before but now you should really
have the throne Jon sauce is the one he
kind of want to keep that from unless
you want an insurrection against
Daenerys from the north
scheming Jon Snow that or you're just
dumb as hell I mean I know the whole
like their family know Ned Stark kept
that entire secret from his family
captor from his wife his kids his wife
thought he [ __ ] another girl when he
was out there to war he took that hit
man he took that knee to keep that
secret or you're just gonna blow the
whistle on it now I'm just saying you do
your father who was not actually your
father a disservice
I mean fact that a dragon was killed out
of nowhere Daenerys now has one dragon
just one dragon no Dothraki or did gray
worms say half the Dothraki he said half
were lost I don't know if he was talking
about the unsullied or the Dothraki what
is a lot of what she acquired overseas
for this battle is now not with her at
all and I don't know who's gonna kill
Cersei Lannister I know that I'm pretty
sure the Hound is going there to kill
his brother or be killed by his brother
they're gonna kill each other I don't
know Jaime Lannister might be going
there to kill Cersei I doubt he's going
there to save her life I think he said
that to Brienne so she just
accept the fact that he can go and she
just let him go I mean that's a classic
thing dudes do in movies like this shows
like this and everyone really has a good
reason to kill Cersei Lannister no one
has a reason to let her just live but if
Daenerys is willing to wipe out a bunch
of innocent people to take Cersei off
the throne yeah I think Varys has a very
good point but that's why I like this
episode because this episode brought it
back to the dialogue two perspectives
the politics the scheming now we're back
to the game of Thrones I personally like
that so those are my thoughts on episode
4 of season 8 of Game of Thrones and as
promised among the people who have
reacted to Game of Thrones and tag me
and those reactions on the Stardust app
here is the first winner who's won a
trip for them and a friend to Los
Angeles California for the game of
Thrones series finale party his winner
was picked at random via a numbered
generator as random as I can make it and
that winner is Jason Snead you have won
a trip for you and a friend to go down
to Los Angeles California for the Game
of Thrones series finale party
congratulations Jason you were chosen by
fate itself I start us is putting it on
they'll pay for the flights that's right
a flight on someone else's dime you find
anything that feels better than that you
let me know so we got another winner to
announce next week so keep those
reactions coming keep tagging me and I'm
hot it's just getting started actually
two more episodes Game of Thrones it's
almost all right so Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 4 have you seen it what
did you think about it you like that
it's on track for the grand showdown for
King's Landing in the Seven Kingdoms or
in the previous episode just piss you
off so much you just don't care anymore
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]